this actually is brings us to one of the
tough choices among many tough choices
that our students are facing each each
day as they think of themselves as
activists they're faced with they can
save children they can actually pay for
malaria pills they can donate money or
time to an art museum they can provide
resources to a preschool program they
can buy solar panels for homes but it
requires them to compartmentalize some
of these issues that can be quite
distressing is that a necessary talent
to be able to be effective and and to
live as graciously and as happily as as
you have just described probably so but
it doesn't have to be so for example i
think these young people have three
choices in the world they getting engage
in social justice activity they can
engage in social service activity or
they can do nothing at all those are not
really the only three but these are
three choices they have well I've always
thought if you create a world where
there is social justice there will never
be any need for social service that if
you have a community that provides
social justice that require social
justice the need for social service will
diminish so I've chosen to work for
social justice but I think Social
Services wonderful is wonderful pursuit
in life and the things they can do in
that regard will benefit to the the will
resound to the benefit of others and
we'll make them feel like much better
people so I wouldn't encourage them to
have to feel they have to do one or the
other in fact I think you can do both or
all but they have the important thing as
they do something that they do something
because doing nothing really means
you've joined the other side and you
don't want to do that